he looks like America and sounds like
America but we're actually at the
headquarters of Germany's Social
Democratic Party as the Democrats abroad
get together for their global convention
there are 13 delegates up for grabs and
the overwhelming majority are for the
so-called democratic socialist bernie
sanders bernie's older brother Larry
says that's not surprising his policies
of domestic policies in particular free
universal healthcare Lee paid leave from
work for various reasons very close to
what people experience in European
countries most of those present are
pretty certain Hillary Clinton will get
the nomination they can live with that
as long as the Democrats stay in power
the conventions German hosts a full of
praise for Obama's achievements over the
past seven years you have achieved a lot
as Democrats in the last year's and you
can be very proud of that Fred but there
is one person threatening to spoil the
party Donald Trump could a populist
billionaire really become president of
the United States of America for me as
well it is a wonder that someone who's
fair so many characteristics of a
carnival barker a narcissistic carnival
barker could come this far it would be
the worst thing in the world and I might
not want to ever go back to the United
States I might just stay in Mexico and
that'd be hard because I my family is in
the States but when it comes down to it
most here are sure that Clinton will win
the election in November even if the
Democrats abroad are throwing their
weight behind Sanders for now giving him
nine of their 11 delegates